welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode eight I hope you're
doing well
amid the insanity that is North America
right now I'm still in Belgrade having a
fantastic time with my hubby and my
child and my father guess who I'm having
on the podcast next week him first
podcast with jbp in over a year
I hope you're excited because it's a
doozy today's episode I spoke to Chris
Williamson he's the host of the podcast
modern wisdom in an entrepreneur and
personal coach he's a hub of knowledge
surrounding productivity and bettering
yourself he also has a life hacks manual
that you can download so you don't need
to take notes during the show everything
is linked in the show notes and I highly
recommend downloading his manual we go
over a lot of helpful info but like I
said everything's in the show notes you
can go to Chris we'll x-com slash mp4 a
free copy of his manual without further
adieu
[Music]
miss Williamson welcome to my podcast hi
how are you um I'm doing okay things
could be better but things could
definitely be worse how are you doing
yeah I'm good thank you
good enjoying a rest sunny UK for a
while oh yeah not jealous
okay so would you please introduce my
audience to who you are give a bit of a
background okay so my name is Chris
Williamson I'm a business owner
from the northeast of the United Kingdom
I've run club nights for the last 13
years which means I've stood in the
front door of events watched a million
people go in and get drunk I started a
podcast about two and a half years ago
called modern wisdom before that I
actually did some reality TV love Island
take me out blue tick on Twitter all the
big stuff all the headlines and then
started this podcast a couple of years
ago really fortunately got some
fantastic guests on got to spend a lot
of time with some super interesting
people and now during lockdown there's
not a lot of nightclubs which means that
podcasting stepped up an awful lot I
have an interest in humour performance
in productivity we talk about philosophy
psychology life hacks we've had a porn
star on we've had a girl who created the
UK version of all new fans on so to a
broad spectrum of guests and yeah that's
what I do I'm interested and constantly
curious and looking to satisfy that and
I guess that is why I enjoy doing the
podcast so much getting to speak to it
interesting people different people okay
well I feel like there's a lot we could
cover but what I wanted to focus this
podcast on specifically was productivity
because I feel like you're kind of a
productivity grew I know that you've
read a lot of productivity books and I
figured it'd be easier just having you
on then going to each of those
individual people so I'm just gonna
bombard you with a whole bunch of
questions that I really want to know the
answers to I also ask my audience if
they had questions so I have some from
them but most of these are from me
so I'm gonna I'm gonna get started with
just oh well let me think how should we
start this let's start with productivity
apps
why don't we define it first just so
that everybody knows what I say and
deciding we're gonna go ahead go ahead
go nuts so productivity used to be in
the olden days in machine technology
world it was the difference between your
inputs and your outputs it was how much
workforce or raw materials did you need
in order to get the outputs now in a
knowledge work society what we're
talking about is being able to do more
in less time with less stress more
easily that's what you're trying to
achieve right so it's still the same
it's still inputs and outputs and that's
the way that people should see it any of
the tools that they add into their life
what is this helping me to save he
allowed me to save money is helping me
to save time has helped me to say stress
does it allow me to automate things you
know so yeah when we talk about apps and
and strategies and routines and all this
sort of stuff all that you're trying to
do is get more done with less stress
more easily and there's some things that
you have to do in life right like you
have to file your taxes you have to
insure your car you have to go to the
grocery store the quicker that you can
get to have to do is done the sooner you
can get to the get to dues so you get to
play with your kids you get to go on
holiday you get to do a project that you
care about and obviously if you can get
that done more efficiently as well you
can allow yourself to be more present
you can have less stress you can get
more of that done as well so you get to
condense down the time of the have to do
and you get to expand the time if they
get to deuce just speed up playing with
your kids yeah you play with them at
hyperspeed give them loads of caffeine
all the blue it's a blue Smarties isn't
it the blue Smarties are the ones that
send through the roof and then once I've
got that then they're flying yeah
so you wait to do apps productivity apps
well I just want really easy ways to cut
down a whole bunch of work that people
just aren't aware of okay so I made a
handbook of 200 life hacks that I think
we're probably going to cover quite a
lot of today so if there's people that
are listening and they're saying they're
concerned about the fact that having to
write them all down if they just go to
Chris will XCOM slash MP so I made a
sign-in for your guys so they can just
access this full list for free Chris
will XCOM slash MP so starting with Apps
things that I found to be quite useful
for me straight up reminders on your
phone so David Allen the guy that wrote
getting things done his quote is the
mind is built for having thoughts not
holding thoughts what that means is that
your brain is great at being a decision
engine but it's quite a shitty office
and as we have more and more different
projects going on we've got a lot of
different things that we need to try and
remember a lot of the time people use
their brains as libraries rather than as
decision-making engines so straight up
use the reminders on your phone for
everything I need to get cat food I need
to file my taxes by this day it's
Mikayla's birthday on Tuesday say to
repeat every year at that time you know
like you can get away you can automate
straight off the bat so much of the
stuff that you have to do in your life
because our weeks are quite routinized
and then our months are quite routine I
say even girls like I'm gonna menstruate
at this time and I'm gonna do this at
this time you know I mean like I've got
to get cat food every three months or
whatever it might be yeah try and
automate as much of this stuff as you
can so straight off the bat reminders
and that's native there's no one's phone
that doesn't have that now you can step
that up a little bit more there's an app
called things three or OmniFocus they're
two productivity apps that are both
quite popular especially if you're using
David Allen's getting things done method
but the reminders app on your phone is
more than sufficient and just constantly
thinking why am I remembering this thing
and just getting out of your head like
the biggest red pill that David Allen
gave me when
custard with him was you should never
have any thought more than once unless
you want to have it and that we realize
that's the implication of that it it's
pretty crazy because how many times two
people have a thought over and over
obsess about it again and again I so get
that taxed and I still go get that tax
and it's like put it into a place that
you trust leave it there and it'll tell
you when it needs to be done and that's
it you just make the decision right
you're not holding the thoughts you're
just having thoughts yeah yeah I found
so I think you introduced me to Diego
Forte hopefully I'm pronouncing that
Tiago Forte anyway I've started using
things three and I really like it I also
find a lot of those thoughts that are
ruminating about both things to do if
you put all those in a to-do list
half of those and maybe three-quarters
you don't really need to do what's going
on in my life a big chunk of them is
just indexing your thoughts right so we
have a lot of things that we think about
and this is part of in the getting
things done framework which is what
Tiago follows does the capture process
which is the first part and that's what
things three is really good at it's a
seamless capture process so this is why
Evernote as a another app that people
probably should be using and I tried to
read kill you on this about this for
your writing near the day when we were
talking like if you are opening a new
word document every time you have to go
and write something please for the love
of all that is holy just stop you have
these project these products like
Evernote or even Apple notes on your
that's native on your phone and on your
laptop and they will nest documents
inside of master folders inside of
projects you can search through them
more easily you don't have to have them
saved just scattered across your desktop
or across your computer like which is it
feels primitive you know like come on
it's 2020 switch over it feels primitive
but beforehand but that's the problem
with all of this stuff right and it's
the same with learning anything like you
you learn something and then can't
remember what it was like to not know
that thing you know like you learn you
do
to meditation do a couple years of
meditation and you realize what it feels
like to be lost in thought and then you
can't remember what it used to feel like
to not recognize when you were getting
lost in thought and you're like this you
know so yeah all of these things I also
need to kind of caveat you've introduced
me very complimentary but I'm not in no
way am i any guru in this I've just
happened to expose myself to a lot of
these guys so any of the things that I
put across their correct pre-human it's
their brilliance and any of the mistakes
that are made presume that it's my
idiocy Thiago Chris sparks from the
forcing function is fantastic David
Parral Taylor Pearson all of these guys
that I look up to in the productivity
space are amazing but I'm gonna blender
some of this stuff right so when we mess
up that's my fault
so things three talking about reminders
Evernote as well is a fantastic force
for that moving into some other bits and
pieces extensions for google chrome so
pocket is a fantastic read later up if
you don't have a read later up I highly
recommend it again we're talking about
getting stuff out of our heads if you
are someone who likes to read has a lot
of suggestions from articles from
friends and stuff like that what do you
what do you do someone sends you an
article think to yourself you're
listening now what do you do with that
article link like do you just put it in
your favorites that is it going into a
note somewhere that you're never going
to look back at no you need to use a
read later up pocket is what I use
Instapaper is another popular one but
pocket has a inbuilt text-to-speech
transcription so it means that you can
turn any article into an audiobook so
let's say that someone sends you an
article you save it to pocket it's super
easy if you just google pocket it'll
come up with there's an extension for
Google Chrome there's an extension on
your phone as well which matches up with
all of your reading lists let's say that
you get sent something all that you need
to do go on a phone and press the little
headphone button at the bottom and it'll
just speak the entire thing to you which
is crazy because so I started using
Instapaper and I only started I always
use pocket and then I read Thiago are
you sure that's not just because you
British accent and that is actually
supposed to be Tiago or did he tell you
it was Tiago I intro'd him on my show is
Tiago and he didn't correct me
so really doesn't mean anything this is
a rat this is a rat time where it might
be his fault if he didn't correct me and
I've said it should be ta go I don't
know I've never seen that word and
looked at it and thought yeah ta go no
I'm pretty certain but I could have
anglicized the hell out of it who knows
okay anyway I've started using
instapaper and just because he suggested
it and everything he suggested seemed
like a good idea so I switched over from
pocket to Instapaper can you forward
emails directly into pocket I don't know
why would you be forwarding emails into
pocket or Instapaper what's your purpose
for using a read later app for your
emails people send me scientific
articles quite frequently so it's
somewhere to store it so I've been using
Evernote in case anyone's listening I
didn't know this but you can set up
Evernote so that you can just forward
emails into it which is amazing to keep
track of emails but and you can do that
with instant paper so the reason I
switched over was because of that I'm
not sure if you can do it on pocket my
phone oh that wouldn't be a feature that
I would have used but yeah I got that
that's pretty cool other stuff so let me
let me give the people that are
listening like the main productivity
changes that I think that they need to
make and these for you and now six
months old from one we met so it'll be
interesting for you to revisit them and
maybe he could sort of give some of your
experiences but first things first you
need to sleep with your mobile phone
outside of your bedroom like if you
still have your mobile phone in your
bedroom when you go to bed at night
you're just down regulating the quality
of sleep that you're going to get you
can't get to sleep on an evening it's 11
o'clock at night you've tried to get
sleep you're struggling you're tossing
and turning for 20 minutes then you turn
over and just you know that your phone
is there it's just this sort of tether
in the side of your mind that's saying
oh I could just just there's some cat
videos YouTube just a second read it you
know just a second away then you pick
your phone up blue light is absolutely
terrible for improving your sleep
quality so that's bad
plus you've got high stimulus time when
you're supposed to be winding down plus
you don't know what you're gonna come up
against at the moment there's tons and
tons of real sort of quite worrying
merciless content out there you know so
you that's not this is not a conducive
environment to go to sleep in so take
your charger now whoever's listening if
you're in your house do it now take your
charger from the wall next to your bed
and go and put it in the kitchen or in
the living room or somebody you can't
reach perhaps on the other side of your
bedroom at the absolute least the only
reason that people don't do this is
because they're so I use my phone for an
alarm clock right okay radio alarm
clocks have been around for probably
nearly a hundred years and they're about
five pounds on Amazon my advice would be
phone outside of room means that you're
not going to use it late on a night time
it also means that you're not going to
use it first thing in the morning
because you're forced to get out of bed
at the very least to then go and touch
your phone you can't sit in bed we've
all been there you know especially if
you're on holiday and you inevitably
kind of all of your routines go out the
window
phones next to the bed you wake up it's
a different time zone
there's tons of stuff to check 45
minutes go by you're still in bed all
you've done is just click you're off all
of your notifications so that's a really
big change and I think almost
immediately that has quite a profound
impact on people's quality of sleep and
therefore the quality of life yeah I can
back that up I currently do not do that
because I don't really have a reason I
just I'm just not doing it and my
quality of life is significantly lower
yeah it's just it's just discipline with
this stuff but again the point of a lot
of the strategies that we come up with
if they're not just apps and things like
that we want to make doing the thing we
want to do easy and doing the thing we
don't want to do hard right so it's
called stacking the deck you want to
stack the deck in your favor if you
don't pack your gym kit the night before
ready for you to go to the gym in the
morning it's going to be more difficult
for you to go to the gym in the morning
but you know that you want to do it so
make it easier stack the deck in your
favor don't forget to defrost the
chicken so that you can prep your meals
tomorrow because if the chickens not
defrosted you can't cook
meals which means you don't eat the
meals which means you're more likely to
break your diet by going to fast-food
places around the corner you know to my
podcast has a perfect diet ok cool
we've managed to get what twenty minutes
in you haven't used the word gluten yet
so I'm quite impressed
the reason you're not having good sleep
is because of gluten the reason that
you're struggling with your productivity
documents and a bunch of different
locations is because I'm gonna do it
I just know yeah so we've got phone
outside of bedroom okay that's made a
big difference something else that I
would suggest when it comes to sleep and
morning routines would be to use a
sunlight alarm clock so they're about 25
30 pounds on Amazon again all of this is
listed in the ultimate life hacks list
which is Criswell XCOM slash MP sudden
light alarm clock means it's a gradual
increase in the brightness of a lamp
over the course of about 15 to 30
minutes before you wake up and then if
you're not awakened you haven't turned
it off by that then it makes sound what
this does is it starts to regulate the
cortisol and the melatonin levels it
helps to reset your circadian rhythm
it's really really good especially in
the winter months if you're somewhere
like Canada where you've got or the UK
where you've got quite short days and
long nights dark mornings it's good to
get some brightness up there and that
really helps so again you can see how
we're now starting to stack these things
on top of each other we've got a phone
outside of our room we now have the
requirement that we need to be able to
have something else that's going to wake
us up so okay how can we optimize
perhaps another product that we could
add in there so next up on morning
routines I would just say you have to
have a structure to the beginning of
your day it's the only time that you
have in the entirety of your day which
is purely yours you're gonna within a
couple of hours of waking up you're
gonna have to do with the kids you're
gonna have to deal with the boss you're
gonna have to deal with traffic you're
gonna have to deal with all of the other
stuff social media phone work
requirements everything right the
morning is the only time that you have
even on an evening you don't have that
even if you were in solitude because
you've still got the memory and the
thoughts that are ruminating from
earlier on
day but upon waking you have this period
maybe 20 minutes maybe 30 minutes if you
could push it a little bit longer that
would be great
so don't touch your phone you don't need
to check your phone within 30 minutes of
waking up you also don't necessarily
need to have caffeine so it advised
having salt lemon water and eau de about
Aubrey Marquez on and he's a big big
proponent of this which is kind of like
an adrenal cocktail salt lemon water big
glass of water and get some sunlight
exposure even if it's just standing in
the window with the window open for five
minutes that will make your morning so
much better than sitting in bed casting
out what's happened on Twitter overnight
like my friends had an argument someone
still drunken out from a bla bla like
you know what's happening on snapchat
now like that is an anxiety cocktail we
don't want that we want to feel nice and
refreshed you know and ready at ready to
attack the day so that's something I
mean I pushed this pretty hard onto you
right as well and I think that it made a
pretty good impact for you when you were
able to do it yeah when it lasted yeah
it made a huge difference not sleeping
well sleeping with my phone outside my
bedroom was probably the biggest one
because of the whole social media thing
and I'm getting a lot of negative
feedback all the time tomorrow today
actually for example today was really
bad I woke up in the morning I
immediately checked Twitter which I
don't do as a rule and I did anyway and
I got really riled up about something
and then that was it that's you day
right
but that's the signature you know so
there's two there's two ways that I
reset my day one of them is sleep but
the other one's training and I actually
find that going and training has more of
a mood reset than sleeping does I carry
over more of my mood from the night
before to the next morning than I do pre
and post-workout so having again with
these things we don't want to get
ourselves into these situations where
where we are riled up when we see
something which gets us gets us going
but inevitably it's going to happen so
think about how you structure your day
as well they're like okay so maybe I
could train around about mid-morning or
lunchtime or evening time and that's
going to give me that sort of release
and reset again cold showers in the
morning is a fantastic way to really
give you a mood boost it's like the
easiest cheapest thing you can do they
actually is cheaper than taking a hot
shower technically as well so
you know it's that's a great hack for
that do you the main lifestyle changes I
would get people to do buy an automatic
car is a slightly bigger one than by a
buy a sunrise alarm clock and I know
that this might sound stupid if you're
from North America right because you
guys no one drives stick over there but
in the UK and wherever people are
listening they can tell you they can
give you a tweet or comment below or
whatever but so many people hold on to
this like I don't know this nostalgic
notion about why they should be in
control of changing gear and it's just
people that have never spent enough time
in an ok automatic car but basically you
can get to do what some INGOs do
flamingoes sleep with half of their body
asleep at once and then the other half
of the body asleep that could be you
every time you get in your car imagine
how beautiful of a situation that would
be that could be you this could be the
life you lead but no you thought you
wanted to be involved in changing the
gear of your car so you need to get an
automatic car you need to have a morning
routine you need to sleep with your
phone outside of your bedroom another
one would be go sober for an extended
period of time
I would advise 28 days 90 days or six
months and the reason for that is
gluten-free I'm just sticking that in
there so yeah you haven't even tried
that have you
you think sobriety is a thing try going
gluten-free first I stopped eating pasta
you made me stop eating pasta in that
wait for you that's is that nothing I
still have biscuits
you hate biscuits yeah yeah sobriety so
a lot of people's alcohol use is
programmed not elected what I mean by
that is that you drink not because you
want to drink just because it's
something you do it's something that's
being instantiated through your routines
what your other friends do people from
university school whatever it might be
again my advice would be just take a
break take a really focused break say
you're going to challenge yourself for
28 days 90 days or six months and the
way I would put that in is once every
year I would do 28 days dry January or
sober October a great times to do that I
would say once every two years to do 90
days and then once every five years to
do six months the reason for that is
apart from all of the health benefit
apart from all of the extra time money
and calories that you will get by not
drinking the main thing is that then
when you choose to if you choose to
reintegrate alcohol into your life
you're going to do it on your terms
right it's not going to be just because
it's programming this is what I've done
for the last 10 years in my life 20
years of my life I'm doing this because
I'm choosing to do it and honestly like
those changes that you make automatic
aha
morning routine phone outside of bedroom
focused periods of sobriety so much
low-hanging fruit in there you know
before we even get into read later apps
and setting reminders and doing bits and
pieces like that you have to think like
what's the foundation that all of this
is being built on top of you can have
the most optimized read later app and in
the world but if your morning routine
consists of you chugging down a hole a
huge coffee whilst scrolling through
snapchat then getting into your manual
car to get rid of last night's hangover
like it's not going to be a fad that's
right
no matter how's optimized here at your
Evernote is okay that's a good point I
need to get back on that oh the other
thing that you told me like a number of
months ago that you incorporated and was
meditation just a bit of meditation
which was helpful to me and writing down
things to get them out of your head in
the morning again the way that I would
structured is I've gotten morning
routine mastery master class that is
again on Criswell XCOM people can just
go in there and have a look at that
which will great guide you through how
to build the perfect morning routine but
there's four buckets that people need to
fill in my opinion for a morning routine
they need to move they need to reflect
they need to learn and they need to
prepare so move is get sunlight exposure
get fresh air ideally a walk for around
about 10 minutes reflect would be
journaling so artists pages by Julia
Cameron is a fantastic approach I know
Thiago is a big fan of that are not
respectful of that that involves writing
three pages of unbroken text just mind
dump what's in your head how do you feel
my foot aches my
I've got I've got Bo I didn't see very
well I've got blah blah blah blah
whatever it might be right
that's artists pages the six minute
diary is a product that I've used for
the last three years now and is three
questions in the morning three questions
in an evening and a weekly task that
you've got to complete and that has been
really great for me it's three things
you're grateful for how I will make
today great and a positive affirmation
all that we're doing here we're just
getting ourselves out of it out of the
thinking about what other people think
about us and into that reflective space
again remember what I said about that
morning time is really good to just
allow yourself to sit with your thoughts
you know without the input of other
Minds so Cal Newport in deep work has
this fantastic definition of solitude
where he says most people think solitude
is being on your own and you would say
oh I was I was in solitude while I was
driving in the car you're like well were
you because you had the radio on and you
were taking phone calls every 10 minutes
that's not time away from the input of
other minds that's not true solitude
true solitude would be you genuinely
being just on your own just with your
own thoughts so again we're slowing that
down
meditation headspace fantastic Sam
Harris shout out waking up up is
fantastic as well I think if you use the
code modern wisdom you might get three
months off or something I'm not an
affiliate scheme I just remember they
say two pages ago insight timer is the
most used meditation app by meditation
minutes on the planet and I bet most
people insight timer so it's a little
bit like Skillshare but for meditation
so it's got a bunch of free and paid
courses it's a marketplace but if you're
doing unguided meditation insight timer
is fantastic it's free
it'll track your streaks and it just
doesn't get in the way but you need
something to track how long you've been
meditating to tell you you've done 20
minutes you've done 30 minutes you've
done whatever but it's kind of point
that's paying for a membership if you've
got your own meditation practice that
you're following so insight timer for
unguided guided meditation headspace is
fantastic it'll track your streaks it's
got a whole bunch of different packs
Andy put you come the guy that runs it
is great really wonderful interface
mobile matched up with desktop I think
there's a discount if you've got Spotify
I think there might have some sort of
time at Spotify as
well so that'll be worth searching for
some discount codes as well again all of
this is listed in this big life hacks
list I just can't remember it so people
don't need to write all that waking up
by Sam Harris fantastic release into now
by Cory Allen who is Aubrey Marcus's
audio engineer so if you just google
release into now that'll bring up as far
as I'm concerned the best guided
meditation course that I've ever seen
six weeks of guided meditation it's
probably for slightly more advanced
practitioners but again it's amazing and
the reason all of this different ways to
start meditation the reason you're doing
it is to just give yourself that
mindfulness gap on the morning you know
you don't have thoughts running through
your head you have the opportunity now
to just sit and focus on your practice
without thinking about how Janice cut
you off in traffic earlier on and she's
a [ __ ] or how your boss is really
annoying at how you've got to get the
kids or whatever it might be you have
this period in the morning and James
clear in his book atomic habits has this
beautiful graph where he says if you get
one percent better every day by the end
of the year you're like 38 times better
than you were at the start or is if you
get one percent worse every day
you're for one hundredths of what you
were at the start of the year and this
is what I mean a lot of people their
lives they don't have time to really
work on themselves because they're so
busy great like I I feel for you not
everyone can be 32 single with no kids
and essentially no responsibilities
except for not being hit by open traffic
so I appreciate that you know this is
for me you can have a three-hour morning
routine like [ __ ] fantastic mate but
you can still take some of the
principles of this if you have 30
minutes 40 minutes on the morning to
focus doing your move reflect learn and
prepare you can plus 1% yourself which
just at 45 minutes 30 minutes on the
morning you can go to bed 1% better than
when you woke up no matter what happens
and think as well about how many big
wins you've got in like your day can be
terrible you can have two you can have
two car crash meeting with your boss you
can have the kids kicking off at school
but you go to bed and you know well yeah
at least I got at least I did my
meditation and I did my journal
did this stuff you know like it's you've
kind of blocked off a bit of time that's
just for you and I think that's really
special for people yeah
and coming from somebody who has a
toddler and doesn't have any like time I
feel like I'm overwhelmed all the time
it is possible to wake up an hour
earlier and force yourself to go to bed
a little bit earlier and I think the
most helpful things I found were like
you said sleeping with your phone
outside your bedroom 10 minutes of
meditation and I use head space but head
space is easy it has this like guy or a
woman with a really attractive
Australian voice and they do something
simple like envision your body filling
up with gold which I used to think was
you know kind of hippie-dippie [ __ ]
basically but ten minutes of that will
really help you stop ruminating
especially if you're prone to anxiety
and then a little bit of exercise and
I've found when I get stressed out I
have bought rollerblades and going just
15 minutes of rollerblading it's really
hard to be in the same head space
especially when you're trying not to
wipeout wild rollerblading and other
people yeah I'm pretty good I'm better
than that I'm just I'm just beyond the
point of me wiping out but I can
definitely swerve to avoid people cool I
mean again people who are if there's
anyone out there that does tend to
struggle with depression the almost all
of the problems in life can be fixed
with a training session a good night's
sleep
a big glass of water a walk or I'm not
going to say what the fifth one was
going gluten free yeah probably it would
be getting rid of all of the biscuits
out of your house but my point is that
so much of your mood is within your
control right and you've just hit the
nail on the head there having a cold
shower I challenge anyone to stand in a
colder shower they can for two minutes
step out and tell me that they feel the
same as when they went in like you don't
you don't feel the same you might
yeah you're right okay so we've got
ourselves through the morning routine
let's talk about some stuff to do with
work now maybe so anyone that is on Mac
Alfred is a add-on app that you use the
main functions alfred is a game changer
for a lot of people it's a huge search
tool so it allows you to search through
the same way spotlight would do on your
MacBook at the moment it's not available
for Windows so anybody that's still on
Windows first off get off Windows please
like come on it's 2020 but once you've
got your MacBook once you've spent a
couple of grand on a MacBook then you
can download Alfred for about twenty
dollars and it allows you to have a
unlimited clipboard manager so usually
when you're copying and pasting stuff
you only have the last thing that you
copied Alfred allows you to have up to
the last 200 things that you copied so
you don't ever need to keep on switching
between two different windows anymore
you can just copy all of the different
stuff in separate sections as much as
you want and then you can go across and
you've got this huge big clipboard
manager and it's really seamless you
don't need to use your mouse you can
just do everything on like on the
keyboard which means it's really quick
another thing that it has is snippet
text expanders so some people might be
familiar with this on iPhone which is if
you have a text replacement basically
you can write in a sentence a word an
entire document paragraphs of text or
even paragraphs with line breaks in type
in a shortcut and then that shortcut
will expand out into whatever it is so
for instance I have
EML expands out into my email address
add1 expands out into my home address ad
d2 expands out into my office address
but then inv one expands out into my
full 500 words
Podcast invite email fully formatted
with everything Lord Alfred Alfred yeah
exactly
Wow I actually downloaded Alfred I just
haven't taken the time to figure out how
to use it yet I'm not right now when I
call
being paste things like screenshots I
will take the screenshot put it into a
Word document save it as a picture so
that sounds like a better way to go
about it I'm just have to I just I
haven't learned how to use it yet but
but again like once you do it you'll
never know what life was like without it
but until you know it right it just is
what it is like this is the universe so
yeah
alfrid phenomenal like such a
game-changer Pomodoro Technique for
productivity is something that's really
really popular it seen a resurgence
surgeons recently essentially the
Pomodoro Technique Pomodoro is the
Italian word for tomato and you do 25
minutes of focus work followed by a
five-minute break you do that four times
then you take a 15 minute break now
people might think well hang on if I
don't take that five-minute break I can
get five minutes more work done but it's
the same as saying if I don't ever take
a rest day from the gym I can make more
games yeah but you're not just inputs
process outputs robot you're an
operating willpower driven machine and
the reason that you have 25 minutes
is that a five minute break is never
more than 25 minutes away the point of
the Pomodoro itself the reason you do
the 25 is because it allows you to focus
your attention onto a single task for
that time so many people are just I
don't know what I'm supposed to do I'm
trying to multitask could do a number of
different things Pomodoro Technique is a
good way to do that be focused Pro by ex
wave is the program that we all tend to
use again on top of that in terms of
task management you can only have one
top priority at any one time by
definition like there can only be one
top priority and if you think you can
multitask you're wrong multitasking is a
loser's game multitasking is four
Muppets as Ben Greenfield sensing an
excellent at multitasking it's
impossible it's impossible task
switching having more than two tasks
open at one time reduces your overall
productivity by 40% so basically just do
a thing
you don't need to be doing two things at
once just finish the email that you're
finishing now then send the message
you're going to send then go and pick
the kid up from school don't try and
send the email whilst doing the message
whilst picking the kid up because all of
the tasks they don't add to increase the
value of all of them they subtract a way
to leave you with less so
so you said focused pro the focus pro is
the brow yeah it's the program that you
can use to track your Pomodoro's it's a
little timer in the corner of your
screen which also is quite good counting
down from 25 so so it tells you you can
kind of have a little glance up and let
you know what you're doing it also has a
space for you to put in what is the task
you are working on right now which again
reminds you I am doing this thing and
then once you've done it you've finished
that and it will tell you what's the
next thing you're doing what's the next
thing you do which is important that's
cool
okay I think I'll try and implement that
after Alfred for sure okay well is there
more I mean you have 200 life hats and
life hacks too right yeah let's stick
with productivity so it's not good
sidetracked here well I think
productivity kind of bleeds into
everything else right like is meditation
part of productivity well does it make
you yeah does it permit you to do things
in your life with less time greater ease
less stress like yeah of course it does
so a sauna is part of a productivity
regime training is part of a
productivity regime the presumption is
if you are happier more balanced
healthier you're going to be able to do
more of the things that you want to do
okay so the stuff for productivity I
mean Alfred Alfred will change a lot of
people's lives something that I've been
playing around with recently anybody
that has a Kindle there is a Google
Chrome extension called send to kindle
for Google Chrome and what you can do if
this is me talking about a paperwhite
I'm gonna guess it works for an oasis it
might even work for the Kindle app on
your phone but I don't know why you
would do that when you can use pocket
which is also a read later up my point
is that for me I don't like to
things on phone or laptop because I just
get worse reading experience I'm
distracted it's where I do work and a
lot of people might feel this right that
they feel they struggle to read things
with deep comprehension on phone perhaps
they struggle to focus on other sorts of
stuff on laptop and this is because we
get conditioned to being in particular
mindsets when we're doing particular
things if you're in the kitchen you're
thinking food if you're in the living
room you're thinking TV if you're in bed
you're you know I mean and similarly
most people aren't flicking between
millions of different stimulus articles
with flashing bonging lights on their
Kindle because it doesn't do that the
paperwhite is quite a simple device for
that reason center Kindle for Google
Chrome allows you to turn any article
into a fully formatted Kindle dot mobi
document sends it straight to your
Kindle paperwhite fully formatted it
allows you to change the text size the
fonts it keeps all the formatting but it
just puts it onto your Kindle perfectly
so it turns your Kindle from just being
a book reader to being more of an
article reader you can still do your
highlights you can define words you can
then export the highlights etc but
that's you know especially if you are
the sort of person like yourself you've
got a lot of journals that you want to
read if you try and do it
turn it web page into a PDF send the PDF
to the Kindle email address just comes
out so ugly and it's really hard to read
whereas if you use center Kindle for
Google Chrome it's one click and it just
appears on okay that might be even more
useful than Instapaper
if you're reading longer form stuff I
think it could be cool okay fantastic
well what else do you have I'm coming
I've got questions like an ask I just
want to cut find some questions and
let's see what the audience want to know
okay what's a good one well here's one
so some people asked about being
productive what happens if I like
working at night more than I like during
the day like working during the day
totally fine
there's some fairly robust evidence from
what I've seen that people have a
genetic predisposition to be early birds
or night owls have you seen those well I
don't know like I think a lot of my
health problems I felt a lot better at
night so I thought I was a night owl and
it turns out I'm not so my hypothesis is
most people who think that they're more
functional at night it's probably
because something else is up and that's
literally just me guessing but people
are you know we've got cortisol levels
and hormone levels that regulate how we
sleep so I would assume we're not really
built to function better when it's dark
out so I think probably concluding play
would fix that of course it would to me
athlete's foot gluten-free restless leg
syndrome gluten free its life's wife's
cheating on you gluten free let me
finish that one I think if you enjoy
working at night then work at night make
sure that you get eight hours of sleep
if you can
but it's easier for you the people who
have morning
owl routines tend to have more luck in
life and the reason is that their daily
routine aligns with the routines of most
other people that means if you're
waiting on emails because you don't
finish work until 3:00 in the morning
and that's when you send your emails you
can't have that office back and forth
that you perhaps need which puts you at
competitive disadvantage to the people
who work by day you know there's your
sleep routine should if you can align
with sunrise and sunset that's kind of
the rough rule go to bed when the Sun
Goes Down could get up when the Sun
comes up that's it but if people are
night owls work at night that's cool but
account for that don't work at night and
then still try and get up and do the
early bird thing because that's just
sleep deprivation mm-hmm okay that works
do you okay this is a good one how much
how much of success
you think is willpower or habits
willpower is what gets you going habit
is what keeps you going so you need
willpower in the initial to get you over
that inertial force so this is what a
lot of people struggle with that they
try to do a thing and it's really hard
they might look at you going being
gluten-free and having the particular
diet that you do but even you is the
most extreme case of your diet you
didn't just go from eating everything to
just eating beef salt and water
there was an on ramping period right
where you went through okay I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do
this the point is that the start of
behavior change is always the most
challenging bit because you're putting
in all of the work and yet feeling and
feeling all of the discomfort and yet
seeing none of the progress like the
same way that died like meditating
you're going to feel bored feel Restless
getting up on time sleeping with your
phone outside the room all of these
things are going to feel uncomfortable
in the first place so you you need a
modicum of willpower to get over that
but once that willpower drops off which
it will do is inevitably going to drop
off you need something to continue going
through and this is what's stacking the
deck is it's making the things you want
to do easier making the things you don't
want to do harder so that's what is it
70 percent of the thoughts that we had
today we had yesterday so the vast
majority of the things that we do are
done by habit I think 90% of the stuff
that we do is subconscious
so how do they even come up with these
statistics 70% of the things you think
James clear can you tell us how that
happens please if you listen yes I'd
like to know I just think that it makes
a lot of sense though right so much of
the stuff that we do you're not thinking
about breathing digesting most of the
people who don't decide to follow a diet
aren't thinking about counting their
calories are not thinking about what
they're eating the route that they take
in everything everything that you do is
just a form of habit so you're always
drilling habits success is always going
to be a product of everything that came
before it so presumably if you have
someone like Elon Musk who repeatedly
has success
is upon successes upon successes he has
some robust framework which is producing
this over time and if you're someone who
is in a place and thinks well I feel
like I could be more than I am now the
results that you are having now are a
lagging measure of the inputs that you
have that you put in a while ago so
change the inputs if you want different
outputs you have to have different
inputs so decides that you're going to
stick to a sleep and wake cycle decide
that you're going to spend a little bit
of time in the morning doing move
reflect learn and prepare decide that
you're going to not sleep at your phone
in your room and not spend the last half
an hour an hour of a day on your phone
like those things will make such a huge
difference in your life immediately
yeah I agree and they do they have
helped me a lot I was not able to focus
on anything even remotely close to this
before I got healthier so I'd say if
you're like dying of something probably
try and get on top of that first if you
literally can't do these things because
you should be able to like any healthy
person should be able to wake up an hour
earlier and then start implementing some
of these things because they are simple
so when we sort of expand that out from
there as well when you think your dad's
got this quote about we treat yourself
as if you're someone you're responsible
for helping and that's really
interesting you think that you're in a
plane crash in a plane depressurization
before the crash and the masks drop down
from the ceiling what do they tell you
to do they tell you to put your mask on
first before you try to help anybody
else the reason they do that is because
if you are suffocating you are of no use
to the people that are around you or
Barry Marcus when he came on my show
said you don't serve others from your
cup you serve others from the source of
which overflows around your cup and this
is what I think you know people can look
at the strategies of personal
development or behavior change and
self-improvement and stuff like that and
just think well it's all well and good
but it's just it's quite a selfish
approach to the world it there is
certainly a lot of sovereignty
associated with it people just try
gain competitive advantage but the way
that I see it is the in order to be
everything you can be to everyone else
you have to be all that you can be
yourself first like it's pointless
trying to change the world like clean up
your room
right you know it's it's easy to say but
when you have got your own [ __ ] sorted
it makes everything else comes so much
more easily the setback that you have
with the business the challenge that
your brother is facing at work the fact
that you're going through a rocky period
in your relationship the fact that
you're just a little bit disenchanted
with the way that you and your teenagers
speak to each other whatever it is like
that's going to be a lot harder if
you've got an absolutely wack sleep
routine or if you have no idea where any
of the documents that you need to use
your on your computer of gone so sort
your own stuff and then you can serve
other people as well and this is the
improvement imperative as I think of it
the reason that you have to try and make
yourself as good as you can because that
then allows you to raise up the people
that are around you yeah I like that
okay changing topics that a little bit
kind of what are the top books you would
recommend for people trying to figure
out how to I guess sort out their
mornings or their productivity habits
James clears atomic habits is probably
the best book on behavior change it will
be around in 20 30 years time James was
on modern wisdom which is my podcast if
you just search modern wisdom wherever
you're tuning in you can go and listen
to the episode I think it was around
about number 60 or 70 atomic Cabot's is
fantastic it's really easy to read it's
very straightforward
it's very actionable that's it the vast
majority of person development books
should have been a blog post and a lot
of them should have just been a tweet
but that's one of the ones that there
isn't it's it needs 200 pages but super
easy to read I would also say getting
things done by David Allen is fantastic
that's just had an update for the 2015
version it is the og of productivity
systems it's a lot more specific about
the way that you manage
tasks in your life but I think that's
fantastic I would also say
indestructible by near Al is quite good
people that struggle with focusing
single task focus
deep work by Cal Newport is also another
good one that impresses on you it's a
very very big red pill that you've got
to swallow about how little you can
actually get done if you try and do
multiple things at once essentialism by
Greg McEwan will change your life
overnight have you listened to that
podcast yet no I need to do that is so
bad yet so again modern wisdom we've
just an episode with Greg amazing like
just phenomenal guy and the insight from
that you can have anything you want but
you can't have everything you want how
to focus on the vital few as opposed to
the trivial many in life it's just
that's important it's such a hard red
pill to swallow though because you just
you want novelty you want these new
things and then Greg just comes in with
this big British sledgehammer and he
just starts smacking seven shades of
[ __ ] out of whatever it is that you
thought that you could do and you can't
do it you can't do all of those things
you can be the best in the world maybe
at one thing and even Michael Jordan
people have been watching our stuns like
even Michael Jordan sucked quite a bit
at baseball like he was alright at
baseball it was mint at basketball and
like an alright golfer but sucked a bit
of baseball that he was one of the most
biggest overachievers on the planet he
didn't make it work in a different sport
you can be good at one thing so cheesy
thing another book I think is quite
interesting Viktor Frankl man's search
for meaning less prescriptive but I
think understanding the fact that you
have control over the mindfulness gap
between stimulus and response I think
that has a lot of implications for just
how people see themselves and and sort
of productivity over all the insights
into productivity really and kind of
optimizing your life and stuff you can
go down all the rabbit holes you want
but a lot of them again as we've said
they don't scale over time if you don't
have a solid foundation that they're
built on of understanding what do I want
from life why do I want that thing okay
now everything else is just iterations
of that everything else is just me
stepping towards whatever the goal is
but so few people again so everyone
that's listening ask yourself what do
you want in life like truly what would
make this life good and by that I mean
what would have had to have happened in
your life for you to look back at the
end of it and say that was good
if you can't answer that that is the
first place to start [ __ ] it's don't
buy an automatic car you can get your
phone out of your room actually that
takes precedence but like don't bother
with any of the other stuff we've talked
about today ask yourself like you need
to know what you want from life because
otherwise what is all of the
productivity serving yeah why are you
being more productive what is the the
grander journey that you're on and that
could be just being an amazing mom being
a great daughter being a fantastic
friend being a good pillar in your
community could be being an elite
athlete a businessman an entrepreneur
whatever it might be you can be any of
these things a writer or an artist but
the point is until you know what that is
everything else is just kind of
pointless yeah that's a good point
my dad has a program self authoring and
there's a section then it called future
authoring and it allows you to envision
what you want your life to look like and
exactly how to get there and it allows
you to envision what you want what you
don't want your life to look like and
what kind of habits you have to get rid
of so that you don't head in that
direction and that's probably I'd
recommend that as a good place to start
to try and figure out what you want
although I'm definitely gonna be done
you said George macoing George McEwen
yeah Greg McKeown sorry McEwan Greg
McEwan iego essentialism fantastic man
search for meaning also another good
book some other things that people
should probably check out chasing
excellence Ben Bergeron's podcast is
phenomenal especially if you're in
fitness it's not about fitness solely in
fact only half of it is to do with
fitness what a lot of it relates to how
do the daily actions that we take
results in the achievements that we have
over time stuff like that that
a really phenomenal podcast that's
really been it I think in terms of
podcasts I've been following I've been
going down the road yeah books wise one
I've been thinking about them enjoyed
their endurance by Alex which inson is a
book on endurance sports but has so many
implications for getting through
challenging things moving through
difficult times and stuff like that
that's really really interesting the
wave the superior man by david deida
if you're a guy also if you're a guy
who's listening that wants to understand
how to date women models by marc manson
which is his first book is by far the
best book on into gender dynamics that
you're ever going to find amazing that's
really really cool so it's attracting
women through honesty rather than
through NLP pickup line
negging all this sort of stuff it's just
how can you be a better version of you I
unfortunately don't have an equivalent
for women but you don't need anything
you think well it's not that we don't
need anything we do we need a lot but in
regards to in regards to men and women
it's generally men who go out and do the
attracting right sexual protagonists in
the situation you know which is that
which is the challenge right because
you're supposed to be as a man you're
supposed to be capable with women the
standard for being able to attract the
opposite only ever really lies at the
feet of a man but what's interesting is
when you see how lesbian relationships
and gay relationships move forward in
that gays have so much more sex than all
of us
like if you like having sex you should
and you're a guy you really should
consider turning gay because they just
have tons and tons of sex but women in
lesbian relationships tend to still be
you've got to gatekeepers right right
rather than two protagonists which is
why you have that and again that's an
insight from David data's way of a
superior man about the mass
the feminine energy so that's some does
an entire if you go to Amazon Cody UK
slash shop such modern wisdom Amazon
code at UK / shop / modern wisdom there
is a full book list of everything that I
recommend on there it's about 100 books
so I exists as well okay well we should
wrap it up but I have like one last
question and that's I've been asking a
number of the people who came on my
podcast kind of what their we covered
this a lot actually with you but kind of
what their life looks like as a fairly
successful individual so that's like
when do you wake up what does your diet
look like do you exercise when you go to
bed how many hours a day do you work
just to kind of find a pattern among
these successful humans cool so yeah
wake up at 6:00 to 6:30 morning walk
morning routine exactly as I've given it
to you there move reflect learn and
prepare diet at the moment is being done
by Brad Giglio working against gravity
thank you to him it's a wonderful fella
macros are 210 protein 235 carbs and 60
fat that is mostly back loaded toward
the end of the day so I tend to be
fasted until I train around about midday
training at the moment consists of a
mixture of bodybuilding hypertrophy and
CrossFit tends to be around about 90
minutes
that morning period after I've done
morning routine and prep my food and
before I train
I'll tend to try and do my deep work so
creative stuff which might be editing
podcasts recording intros might be
creating stuff for the website like
making this huge big ultimate life hacks
lists for the Union listeners then I
won't do anything more reactive stuff
there so I'll stay off my phone this is
actually quite a big insight I won't use
my phone until probably about 4 p.m.
posts training so there's nothing just
don't check a mic check I forgot what's
up web what's up web yeah that's a big
one huge change how can I forget that so
if you use what's up on your phone you
can get all of the functionality of
whatsapp on your mobile on your desktop
browser go to web.whatsapp.com
scan the QR code on your phone and then
you have everything that you need and
your phone can stay you don't need to
pick it up anymore for your I message on
your computer you've got emails on your
computer you got whatsapp on your
computer
Instagram comm / inbox / DM takes you to
your inbox on Instagram where you can
reply to all of your Instagram inboxes
messenger comm is Facebook with a
facebook Messenger without Facebook so
it's just the messenger portion and then
Twitter again on your desktop if you
want to use these things and again what
we were saying earlier on about how
people operate in relation to the
environment that they're in the
environment that you're in on your phone
will have been drilled unless you're
super disciplined let some freak savage
disciplinarian you're going to be in the
going through clearing off my
notifications swipe on this or there's a
Bing from whatsapp I'll check what that
is like you don't need any of that you
can have all of the functionality of
Twitter or Facebook Messenger or what's
up or whatever it might be without any
of the [ __ ] pings and bongs they can
just stay in the draw final final final
thing before I tell you the rest of my
daily routine leave your phone away from
your desk while you're at work you don't
need it there especially if you've got a
pair of bluetooth headphones like air
pods
even if it rings you're going to know
about it
so leave it away I've given you all of
the tools today so that you don't need
it for whatsapp you don't need it for
iMessage you don't need it for emails or
facebook Messenger or anything there is
no reason to have your phone next to you
at your desk so if you're thinking about
Ben Greenfield what's the best
nootropics that we should be taking or
can someone talk to me about the the
optimal type of binaural beats that I
should be listening to to optimize my
deep work routine it's like is your
phone at your desk okay how about we get
rid of the big elephant in the room
first and then you can talk about the
appropriate grams of l-theanine versus
caffeine to put into your pre-workout
pre-work shake so yes morning time I
won't use anything reactive other than
perhaps checking what's up because it
might be some stuff to do with work no
email of
all that so that to me focusing as best
I can on doing creative output focused
work train around about midday
post-workout will be about sixty grams
of protein forty grams of protein sixty
grams of carbs five grams of fat and
then I'll just eat I'll just graze for
the rest of the day hitting the macros I
mentioned earlier on to ten to thirty
five and sixty evening routine tends to
be phone after digital sunset around
about 9:00 p.m. in bed by ten sometimes
ten thirty
which is why my wake-up time is between
6:00 and 6:30 I'm using woop as my
activity tracker which tells me how long
I've been asleep and that's pretty much
it you know the different iterations and
ways that you can play around with this
stuff it's fine for someone like me who
finds it super interesting but I think
today we've given your listeners
probably a lot of the big headlines of
the stuff that properly moved the needle
you can drill down into each of these as
much as you want but it's the same as
the best training regime is the one that
you stick to every day the best habit
and productivity regime is the one that
you focus on the basics and that you're
able to repeat daily at work okay well
where can people find you I mean you
mentioned your podcast everything but
you might as well reiterate on all your
social so modern wisdom if you enjoyed
this episode I'd love to see you on my
channel so modern wisdom or have you
tuned in Chris will XCOM slash MP Chris
will ex-con slash MP we'll give you the
full ultimate life hacks list that we've
gone through today plus 180 other bits
and pieces and then at Chris well X
wherever you use the internet Instagram
Twitter all that good stuff okay great
well I definitely recommend checking out
modern wisdom I don't listen to very
many podcasts but you have really
interesting people on there so people
should do that but thank you very much
for coming on sharing your productivity
wisdom that's useful I'm definitely
going to start using Alfred for that
copy-and-paste problem I have
it bothers me every time I copy and
paste something that way I just think
there's this is so wrong to be a better
way right that's Alfred yeah well thanks
for coming on Chris it's been a pleasure
thank you
[Music]
you